[Applause]
that's members of the group figure
skating in harlem congratulating olympic
gold medalist nathan chan on his
historic win at the winter games in
beijing chen's mesmerizing performance
dominated the men's finger skating short
program he's known as the quad king for
his impressive quadruple spins chen
became the first asian-american man to
meddle in figure skating singles at the
olympics and he's the first american to
do so in more than a decade and nathan
joins us now in studio nathan good
morning and congratulations thank you
thanks for having me uh the quad king
the other day in my living room this is
true i stood there and tried to do just
one step
how'd that go with no skates on and a
hardwood floor it didn't work out well
so congratulations amazing performance
you seem to be having the time of your
life which is what's interesting about
it how are you feeling now
i feel great um it's been about two
weeks since i competed and a lot of
things have gone on during that period
of time you know there's a lot of media
and a lot of things that are associated
with the olympics but it's been a really
fun ride so far has it settled uh i mean
you've got the metal there around your
neck does it feel real yet
definitely this whole experience has
felt very surreal you know i've dreamed
about this moment for a long time um and
you can never really plan for exactly
what it'll feel like but you know being
able to see some of my family yesterday
and uh
just being able to talk to them
throughout the experience of the games
has been really special i i talked with
you and pyeongchang
after you had lost and not performed the
way that you had wanted to
you said you were going to use that as a
learning experience and how you approach
these games so how did you use that in
the lead up here i definitely think i
mean i learned the most from my mistakes
from the things that i don't do quite
right um and so
2018 i think was a really great
learning experience for me um taught me
how to sort of like set my mind for
competitions how to approach
competitions a lot of what we when we're
competing we're only on the ice for six
minutes roughly you know with including
short program and long program but
there's like hours and hours of training
that goes into it to those six minutes
so making sure you understand how to you
know utilize those hours before the
competitions to the best of your
abilities allows you to perform better
in competition you also though and tony
said that like you had so much fun and
even then even when you didn't place
where you wanted to you seem to
appreciate that moment how are you able
to do that
i certainly think over the past four
years um i've been able to come to
skating with a place of gratitude um and
just like recognizing how lucky and
fortunate i am to have these
opportunities to compete to represent
the us to do all these things that i
love so much you know i spent all my
life uh practicing figure skating but
it's the one place where i feel like
truly at home so to then have the
opportunities to do that
a scale in which that i've been dreaming
about for a long time is really special
you said michelle kwan and christie
yamaguchi uh they're your inspiration
two fellow asian american skaters and
you're the the first men to meddle um
gold medal and men's single
what can we do to diversify the sport
i think we're definitely doing the right
things um and
uh as mentioned earlier with figure
skating in harlem where you know there's
organizations like this that are helping
diversify the sport and it allows
skating to be an accessible sport for
everyone um and
teaming with actually was quite diverse
this time having you know chloe kim
myself vincent joe karen chan and many
others that i'm leaving out um but you
know it's great to be able to have this
body of asian american representation at
the olympics and i think that in itself
is so important can we talk more about
how you get your mind right before the
performance we've been talking about
when you're obsessed i'm kind of
obsessed with it so we know music is
part of it and clearly you like music in
your performance sure
what songs in particular do you use
pre-show to get ready
it really depends on where i'm at
physically i suppose i think it also
depends on where i'm what time i'm
competing i figure if it's like morning
or like where i feel like i need to get
jazzed up a little bit more um i've
traditionally listened to like songs
from eminem from 88 rising um edm songs
loud luxury uh stuff like that to just
get me amped up a little bit as i get
closer to competition or if it's like
later in the day where i'm already
pretty amped up and jazzed jazzed up i
need something that calms me down a
little bit more so like patrick watson
things that are like a lot more slow and
like more
melodic are things that like just help
me get in my zone and then rocket man is
what you perform too right uh and elton
john congratulated you
really love the song are you hearing the
song are you in the performance
well i train this program every single
day many times a day so the music is
like ingrained in my head at this point
in time so um i know where the basic
with the nuances of the music are and
i'm pretty comfortable with the music
but certainly the music especially when
you're in a situation where you know
you're stressed out you're nervous and
then also you get like halfway through
the program you get pretty fatigued
having the music sort of elevate you and
give you energy is really helpful well
eminem's uh song lose yourself is an
athlete's go-to song absolutely for the
pre-game um but that's a great question
that tony asked about the moment are you
an individual that completely loses
yourself and after it's done you come to
or
are you completely aware of every single
thing the smell the feel the temperature
of the moment it's definitely different
there are times where i find that we
enter like this flow state where
everything just locks off and like
you're just like so
just in this trance you know throughout
the program but those are the times
where i find i skate the best when i'm
in that state but it's not always there
and i think that this time around like i
definitely wasn't in that specific flow
state but i've also learned to adapt to
when i don't feel that flow state and
still
try to have confidence knowing that i
can still do my elements even if i can't
reach that zone i think people knew in
2018 we'd see you back in 2022.
people are already wondering and i know
you've been asked what about 2026 is
this something that you can see because
that dedication in the four years in
between is something most of us can't
even understand
i definitely think i need to think about
it a little bit more 2026 of course is a
very exciting olympics in milan i think
that'll be really cool experience to
have um however you know i just got off
2022 you know i still have four years we
don't care we want to know now
let him relax dana for sure totally fair
but i mean i would it would be very
exciting but right now you know i'm just
embracing this moment and then trying to
live in this present and figure out what
what's to come in the next couple years
is there a deciding factor is there for
you like i need to know by this time if
i'm really gonna do this i think it's
just a progression of time you know it
depends on how you know this next couple
months ago and then i go back to school
in august and then how school goes and
whether it's something that i'm like hey
i'm like just really invested in school
and i don't really consider anything
else or i'm like hey i'm missing this
aspect of my life so it really depends i
think it's just like a day-to-day sort
of process and i don't really want to
put a concrete you know answer on it for
myself what are you majoring in in
school uh statistics and data science
nice i'd take the medal to class if
you'll ever need an hour that should do
it no doubt about it well we'll see you
in milan okay
for the pasta nothing else fair enough
thank you so much